you
[Music]
well hello everybody yeah so today I'm
talking about about super sets I've been
giving super set talks before but this
one I tried to take a different angle a
little bit so usually I run a demo and
usually you know I talk mostly about
what super set is and whether it's
relevant or how it may be relevant for
you and your organization today I'm
talking a little bit more about the
history and about like how it came to be
and some of the decisions we've made
over over over the period of time in
which we've built this community and
this tool so you know you probably use a
lot of open source software and really
often you know you have just no idea of
what's behind this open source software
like what are the faces and who are
building these things and what they go
through as as they grow this software so
I'm trying to address some of this today
before I get started a little bit about
me so that's the slide I get to reuse
all the time so at this point in my
career I'm mostly known for the work
that I've done around superset and
airflow we won't be talking about
airflow here today now at least I won't
be we'll be talking about superset I'm a
digital artist which is not something I
would bring up but I think it's relevant
to talk about this in this context
because really for me when I was working
at at Airbnb on air flow when I started
working on super set that's really where
I started to kind of where my hobbies
where you know after hours and in my
hobbies always playing with electronics
I was doing a interactive art
installation for Burning Man and things
like that so I was writing code for the
the pure pleasure of it and for just
generating images and things that move
and that are interactive so when I
started working on super set I really
kind of found Korea where my my career
started meeting my my hobbies and my
passion so so I've been full-on over the
past like four years or so I think we're
coming close to four years we're working
mostly like focusing on super set I've
been doing a lot of work in the data
engineering space up until
fifteen or sixteen mostly my major
contribution was probably Apache airflow
or starting the project at least and
last year I was I was here talking about
different aspects of data engineering
that are dear to me one was this idea of
applying concepts from functional
programming to data engineering so still
an area of interest to me but like right
now I'm really focusing on data vis I've
been doing data for a long time and more
recently I I left left to go and start
my own thing which is still in stealth
mode so I'm not talking about this today
but a happy to talk to people about that
offline so before jumping into the
history of super set I want to make it
kind of clear and I'm not sure how many
people in the room are familiar with
super set so how many of you like I
think I've done a little bit of research
on super set already
unless my mic alright so so it's
probably a good thing if I do start by
just kind of showing what it is so they
say images an image is worth a thousand
words so here we got right about four
thousand words here and I've got kind of
zoom in of the different the different
apps that are in super sets are really
super set is a collection of three apps
that you can navigate from and - the
first part is this dashboard view where
you can consume dashboard you can create
interactive dashboards and you know set
them up and you know organize organize
your dashboards the second app so from
the dashboard view you can easily get
into this what we call the explore view
so this is web form based approach to
slice and dicing so it's a mix of slice
and dice explore your data from here you
can easily kind of pivot to different
data visualization that we support right
and do a little bit of publishing here
too like things like do you want to show
the legend do you want to adjust the
size of things so so
so really this slice-and-dice view is a
mix of data exploration plus publication
or making your visualization look
exactly like you want it to look come on
clicker don't let me down all right so
that third app inside super set is the
this this sequel IDE so it turns out
it's pretty useful if you are doing data
exploration and you know sequel to have
access to sequel IDE for context to
super set is very much of a web
application and it's a it's a full-on
product that you're installing and your
organization given access to be to
people to and a place where people you
know it's really a tool full-on in the
category of business intelligence or
data visualization so very much a
competitor with tools like you know
tableau looker and and the plethora of
tools in this space
the main differentiator here is that
superset is open source and where
they've got the Apache Software
Foundation so very much an open source
project around visualization but a
product as opposed to a data
visualization library or something like
that right so I think a lot of the open
source projects we have around are
expected to be composed into
applications this is an open source
application so I want to be clear on
that so this is like or semantic layer
so semantic layer is the old term that
Business Objects and MicroStrategy and
and perhaps like liquor are using to
describe the layer that what the
business intelligence product like knows
about the physical database and extra
information on top so I think
historically semantic layers have been
very heavy right like we're before doing
a visualization on a table you would
have to add your table to your semantic
layer and do a lot of upfront work so
there's trade-offs here so if you do a
lot of upfront work where you inform the
system about the table you're bringing
in you're creating your metrics and your
calculated columns then it presumably
makes it easier for people down the line
to come in self-service
use this tool in our case we wanted to
make it really easy for people to just
point to a table and be able to leverage
it right away and kind of get the
semantic layer more as an afterthought
or something that you add on top when
you're ready for it or when you need it
and I think that brings this it links
nicely with this idea so one of the the
philosophy or principle behind Apache
superset is this idea to have like a
very fast time to dashboard so assuming
that you have a data set that has like
dimensions and metrics and you want to
visualize what's in there we want to get
that semantic layer out of you out of
your way and just get you to create this
dashboard very quickly it is enterprise
ready so that means that you know we
have role based access control we know
who can do what in the application and
who can access which data I think it's
very important in this space right if
you have a tool in the data exploration
space to be able to control an audit and
like who has access to what and who can
do what it's also cloud native I'll talk
about that in a in a slide that's coming
up we have we support a lot of
visualization that was always a premise
when I started the project I really
wanted for for superset to take like all
the awesome work and d3 that was done at
the time to make that to commoditize
that make it accessible to people so he
could take any data from any database
any visualization from the
visualizations out there that exist and
bring these things together off of these
50 data visualizations some work very
well like the common ones that are used
all the time you know the line charts
and the tables and the bar charts a pie
chart is like super fine-tuned and then
there's a long tail of visualization
that also work but that you know might
offer less options or are less rich in
some ways I think I think now so we
recently plugin if I'd the visualization
so it makes it a lot easier for people
to to go and create their own
visualization that still work that's on
the way but we're really excited
to open that up and you know see if you
work in genomics so if you work in ml
maybe you can contribute some
visualization that are more specific to
your use cases and share them with our
community
lightweight semantic layer I talked
about this right so not in your face you
don't have to think about it upfront you
you can later on go and inform your
calculated your more complex metrics or
calculated columns but you have to do it
upfront we work with pretty much every
database all that I speak sequel so we
use this library called sequel alchemy
that's a Python library and this library
is not only an ORM but it's also a
sequel toolkit that the ORM is built on
and this this allows us to basically
write sequel and an API that that can be
translated to different sequel dialect
so have this deep integration with druid
I'll talk about that kind of the
founding story like how the project got
started so originally we were just a
front-end this project started it was
really just a front end for druid so
historically we've been kind of growing
with them druid is not an Apache project
to assume we make sure that this these
things work well together and supersets
got this like nice thriving and growing
open-source community so the early days
I said this talk was going to be a
little bit about the history and how we
came to be and I think that's relevant
for people that are you know now
contributing through open source or
looking at maybe starting an open-source
project to to kind of understand and get
get a sample of maybe of how open source
projects come to be so so the context in
which like superset got started and we
went through different names over time
but originally as I said I was at Airbnb
that I believe it was 2000 summer of
2015 there was going to be this
three-day hackathon so I was heavily
hacking on air flow at the time I had
been for probably nine months or so and
I was like I need something different
like I want to do something different
for hackathon and we had people in the
data infrastructure team that we're
running at
GOC on Druid and personally I was just
super excited about druid and what it
could do so druid is this database and
I'm not going to get into a lot of
details about what druid is because
people might be already familiar with it
in this room
but I'm gonna talk about it a tiny bit
so druid is a real-time database that's
an in-memory columnstore distributed and
it allows it you know for us at Airbnb
it allowed us to scan huge amount of
data very quickly right so you can get
into the tens of billions of rows that
you can scan and less then you know a
second or so in real time data which at
Airbnb at the time you know there was
just presto and hive a little bit of
HBase for the vital real-time needs but
we didn't have this like
multi-dimensional time series data base
that druid is there was this great
opportunity
I was also out of Facebook at the time
and if we have X Facebook in the room or
people that have talked to X Facebook
you've probably heard the the about the
technology called scuba that they have
internally at Facebook that's a also an
in-memory real time column store with
that that can answer queries very
quickly so so I wanted to recreate a
little bit the scuba experience so scuba
at Facebook offered the back end and a
front end that worked very well together
here we had druid that was this awesome
database very much like scuba without
that without any open source GUI on top
of it druid this did not speak sequel at
the time it now does so I was like this
is the opportunity to go and create you
know this Explorer view we can slice and
dice data out of druid and open to all
sorts of new use cases that everybody so
that's where it came to be after that
three-day hackathon and after perhaps
like nights and weekends you know we had
something pretty solid that was fun to
play with we had people internally you
know that were getting excited about the
promise the things we could deliver with
this on the other end though we had like
a little bit of a near-death experience
with the project because druid was still
in a state of like alpha
just POC internally at Airbnb and we
didn't know whether we're gonna that's
there was going to be the database of
choice there was P know at the time that
was very early for P know but it looked
interesting and there was other things
we could do it spark streaming an age
base to you know solve some of the
real-time use cases we had so there was
a little bit of a do we want to push
this thing forward or not so over a
weekend since the database of choice we
had was presto there I was like let me
try to make what I have working now
against presto to and while I do this
and while I write you know the sequel
query like this the sequel engine I'm
going to try to make it work with all
sequel speaking databases so that's how
we came to be the name changes are
mostly because panoramix is the name of
the druid in this cartoon called Asterix
it's a Belgian or French cartoon so
apparently there's a company somewhere
in the world named that so we can use
that then Caravelle we decided to move
away from because of its ties to you
know colonization and it folks like
negative emotion and some people so
we're like okay once you see it you
can't unsee it and that's where super
set came came to be hardest problem
naming things right I think a year or so
or a little bit less I think it's a year
and a half in the life cycle of the
project that's I would say a year or so
a little bit more than a year is where
our B&B committed to using druid and we
decided to to create a small team around
it I saw Bogdan earlier we was an early
member of the team so we decided to
create a team of a four engineers put a
p.m. and start pushing superset and
druid forward and people at Hortonworks
heard about this effort they were
interested in packaging druid super [ __ ]
and something called stream set into
their Hadoop distribution so they
reached out to us and they're like hey
guys we would love for your software to
join the Apache Software Foundation we
can help you to do that and you know the
Apache Software Foundation
it's great you should do that with us
and we're going to provide mentors and
champions and you know do all the
paperwork that is required to join the
Apache Software Foundation so they I
think they had really good intentions at
the time they never really turned out so
we're still incubating IB Apache
Software Foundation I would say for
people not familiar with software
Software Foundation or more specifically
the Apache Software Foundation it's an
absolute like great thing right as
someone who's interested in using a
piece of open-source software if you see
that the stant Apache it's great from
your perspective because you know that
the piece of software or the project has
a governance model that is fair and that
and that provides a set of guarantees
that you probably want as a user of an
open-source project for people like me
working on the project that means we
have a little bit more paperwork we need
more rigor around things like release
cadence signing releases there's like
paperwork that we need to provide every
quarter we need yeah we need to make
sure that all the licenses we use are
vetted for so it's all great guarantees
for users and extra work for the
founding team and you know a lot of the
the engineers working on the project are
not that interested in doing that work
so pros and cons here but glad we joined
the Apache Software Foundation this is
the slide about just a project and
looking at some of the open-source
metrics those things that you would see
on github so we have a lot of stars
which is a good thing so I think it
proves that there's really an interest
out there and then people in this room
like just your presence right shows that
people are interested in like open
source in the data space of the stack
right Oh in the data stack our open
source has really conquered the data
stack and at the storage and compute
level stream computation right
everything's open source I think there's
definitely a subset of the people that
and the teams out there that are really
interested in like going full stack open
source for for obvious reasons
so we have this growing community this
is a proven project that has a lot of
users that
at Airbnb and lyft and add these
companies under here and we have like a
lot of very committed engineers working
on this so it's only gonna get better
from this point one thing that I don't
always there that people don't
necessarily get to what open source is
that yes where a dozen people and what
yes that's very a small group of people
to compete with the vendors out there
but we use like literally when you look
at our dependency tree I'm going to talk
about the dependency tree that that we
have on the Python and JavaScript side
there's literally like hundreds and
hundreds of contributors behind the
scene that are working on packages that
we use of course vendors can also use
these packages but but like we're really
you know when you look at some of these
like top-level a open source project
we're an army of people working on these
things so this stack that we use so it's
mostly just JavaScript and a front-end
Python in the backend we move on the
code to react and redux I would say
three years ago when I started a project
at hackathon
I was extremely bad at javascript and
you know using jQuery and doing all the
things that you probably shouldn't do
anymore and we've got none of that
anymore so learned a lot on this project
and and I think like while superset has
been growing up too so it so is
front-end engineering right front-end
engineering has been completely changed
over the past few years and and we've
been kind of writing this this wave I
could have done a talk on just a
JavaScript build pipeline that we use so
we use like tons of libraries were
dependent on so many things right on the
date of his side and you know at some
point our JavaScript bundles were so big
they were like 20 or 30 Meg's so we had
to really use like some of the latest
you know technology in the JavaScript
world around web pack to split our
packages and be really creative about
how to load up these packages so envy
and vd3 data uivx blocks right so so for
the visualization code really the common
denominator here is JavaScript so that
means that
you know if you if you have JavaScript
code that can take data and you know
visualize it you can write data
visualize visualization plugin for super
set on the backend side we're in Python
and we're very glad to be I think I
think there's some things that are
really advanced in Python that you
really wish you had in other languages
things like pandas right to do all sorts
of pivoting and time series and window
functions and all sorts of data munging
it's really instrumental to get the data
that comes back from the database you
know into appendage data frame it's a
great place to like pivot things around
and do all sorts of transformation by
the way yeah I did not really get into
this like early on when talking about
just super say I think it's important to
mention that super said there's not like
store data in any way right we do all of
the heavy lifting on your data warehouse
so we assume that the users of super set
have made large investments in there
that it warehouse things like bigquery
like redshift and we push down as much
of the compute and aggregation as we can
down right so the pandas layer is like
you know we get aggregated data and
we'll do like simple transformations on
that see well alchemy is also very I
mentioned it earlier it's very
instrumental to have right this is our
magic on how we can talk to all the
different like sequel dialects and no
one would want to write this code right
of like saying hey if it's sequel server
I'm going to write select or and if it's
my sequel and use a limit clause or this
sort of thing so it's it's been great to
have both the power of like the
JavaScript community and the power of
the Python community I'm not getting
into like the the bowels of superset
where we like would be like looking at
like that like our or the the internal
of superset we would be looking at like
really like what it's made of in terms
of libraries but in Python we have
access to tons of little libraries that
help us very much so this is probably
the slide that took me a little bit
longer to make a little bit more
involved this is what the the
architecture it looks like for a
superset so
one thing that I've done working on open
source projects and air flow is very
much like that I wanted to make it super
easy for people that just want to get
started to to get started and to not
have to set up a bunch of infrastructure
so in its simplest form super set is
really just like a web server and a
metadata database and I talked about
cloud native earlier I use the term idea
being that you know we support standards
and abstractions we use abstraction that
allows you to use your preferred
stacking technologies to run superset so
that means our metadata store is like
behind the sequel alchemy abstraction so
that means you can use my sequel
Postgres mariadb if you're more
adventurous you can use you know things
like sequel server and oracle to write
and the fact that we use WSGI there's
the standard in python for web servers
you can use nginx
Apache web server G unicorn so you get a
bunch of choices similarly if you decide
to set up the cache layer for super set
you have the choice to use Redis
memcache or even implement and extend
your own caching engine for for clarity
I said like superset does not store any
data right so we don't have this concept
of cube like tableau has these tableau
extracts and some other tools you know
will have a way for you to export the
data into some proprietary duplicate
your data into their own cube or their
own like storage layer so here the only
data that we can store if you decide so
or if you configure super set to use a
caching layer is is the cache that is
behind each chart so you can imagine
when you look at one super set
visualization that behind the scene
there's a JSON payload that contains the
data and some metadata about the chart
that is what we store in the cache and
the UI is very upfront to about what is
cache and what is not and when the cache
was taken and it allows you very easily
to force refresh just about anything
now I had to include this is not part of
the architecture a super set but of
course you know we query all of these
these databases here so if your database
speaks sequel very likely that we can
query it easily right there still like a
place and super set where we need to add
a little bit of a layer to deal with the
fact that these different databases are
different so for things like time
functions right so if you're trying to
aggregate by day or by week or things
like subtleties around how databases
handle their cursors or their pagination
interface right so there are ways that
we we can implement some method to deal
with the fact that not all databases
operate the same way here so that in the
async and part of the infrastructure
exists to deal with the fact that a lot
of the lots of web servers are you know
are expected to a web request typically
is expected to timeout at about 30 to 30
seconds to 120 seconds right and we do
know that a lot of analytics type
queries are gonna last a lot longer than
this so we used to reset the query
things like hive and presto and Impala
and redshift and it's not uncommon to
have queries that will last you know
five minutes ten minutes and if it's
hive like who knows how long it might
take right so in this case if you want
so one option you have is to take your
web server and say like I'm gonna crank
up you know the the timeout on it to
like five minutes but that's definitely
not good practice so to deal with this
fact we allow to set up this optional
async infrastructure where the web
server is able to send a message to the
queue and then we have this array of
worker that can monitor these queries
for you and update the database so
that's seamlessly behind the scene you
know we can have long-running queries
that still work I've got a clicker that
works one time out of three I think
maybe I'll use this arrow here I want to
talk about challenges so so far we've
seen we're talked mostly about the past
and the present and I think it's
relevant to talk about you know when
talk
an open-source project of like where
you're at and what are your current you
know challenges so here I'm gonna dig a
little bit into this and and talk about
the challenges were facing so the first
one is you know there was a time where
most of the commits like in the first
like three months or a year of the
project I think I was the main
contributor and I knew everything that
was going on over time we grew to have
hundreds of contributors and this is a
github insights over a period of a month
right so four weeks or so it's a 74 pull
request there's a lot of people
contributing I know most of the people
these people not all of them right and
and no one when you get to a certain
certain point and your open source
project no not any one specific
individual knows everything about
everything that's going on so it's like
distributed knowledge and it can be
really challenging to deal with now for
all sorts of reasons people have
different roadmaps people have different
ways to contribute people agree disagree
on things we don't really have an issue
around consensus as much as just pace
and like keeping up is hard for anyone
working on the project and I assume that
like this is nothing compared right the
Linux like kernel project right where
there's like so many comments that they
had to build their own infrastructure
and had to build to build I get itself
to deal with the fact that things were
so fast-paced
another challenge that we had that we
have that I alluded to is the fact that
we have this gigantic dependency tree
there's this trend in the JavaScript
world they probably aware of that is
like micro packages so when you
sometimes when you import a single
package like here it's written really
small but this is like bable bable CLI
or which depend on something which
depends on a whole array of things and
it's just this gigantic tree that is the
nature I think of JavaScript development
to a certain point these these days but
it does bring challenges all of these
packages are evolving at different pace
sometimes too slow sometimes too fast
luckily NPM is a really good package
repository but but
still right like behind-the-scene we're
juggling with a lot of moving parts we
can pin these moving parts but but it's
still challenging so in terms of scale
right 88 production packages and 68 def
packages it's kind of extreme and that's
not common to a lot of applications out
there is kind of an extreme case here
and when you look at the leaves right so
these are in a number of like top nodes
in our tree the thing we depend on these
things depend on other things and we get
to above like a thousand individual
packages that we depend on fun stuff
welcome to the JavaScript world right
and in Python it's less extreme right we
have 35 direct dependencies and that lis
that leads to like 66 packages but like
behind all of these package there's like
someone or multiple people and a history
of changes and backward and compatible
changes so that's definitely a struggle
this is not the the merge tree this is
not the get representation from our
repository this is just like me doing
image search to find a complex one but
release management becomes really hard
as you get feature branches you get
different releases you get a lot of
people that want different things so
coming up with a stable release is
probably the hardest thing it's easy to
get people to contribute it's hard to
get all these contributions into a
cohesive release and release management
it's not the sexiest thing so so you
know not a lot of people partake partake
in it so it becomes a job of like
keeping up with everyone and getting all
the contributors to pitch in and help
out with releasing but it was so so
we're working on our first official sign
Apache release at this time I've
actually very much like pre 1.0 still
but I think we're on a clear path to
steady Apache releases solid releases
getting to 1.0 like lifting the quality
bar and maintaining it at that level I
think it skipped one coordination a lot
of people means coordination is a
challenge luckily we've got
all sorts of tools to communicate things
like a life slack the dev mailing list
Apache you know offers help there - we
use github we have physical meetings so
we meet between the people at lyft
Airbnb Twitter and Apple you know like
we get together once every two weeks and
talk about you know everything that's
going on project really I try to keep
everyone in sync and everyone aligned
and and often trying to get people to do
I think what's on the next slide here
which is like dealing with some of the
paperwork and things that are less fun
to do so the the the Apache Software
Foundation requires us to do a certain
number of things and and you know we
need to coordinate to make sure these
things get done so I'm going to talk a
little bit about the the roadmap here
that's ahead of us and things that are
actively getting worked on so steady
steady apache approved releases so
that's going on now quality and polish
there's this like so super set started
as a hackathon project as i said earlier
right so now we need to like grow up
from hackathon - you know beta at a lot
of big companies to ultimately something
that's like really enterprise-grade and
something that people love to use and
are delighted with so that means like
less bugs per million interactions that
means things like just polish and better
use the key user flows that work very
well and are that are intuitive we're
kind of like thumbnails and cards so
that means it's not super trivial but
for each assets for each chart and
dashboard we should have little little
thumbnails so that we can have visual
representation of lists of charts let's
list of dashboards and things like that
so that's really like a for visual
appeal and like you know just being able
to visualize the assets that we have
we're also working on embeddable
components and so basically the idea
being that the building blocks of
superset we expose for people to build
other things like data products so I
know there's an
another track I think in a different
room talking about building data
products I'm hoping that you know maybe
next year I'm in that other room talking
about how you can use super set to power
data products so one big component of
that is the data access layer so super
set internally uses api's to talk to
your different databases so it receives
kind of multi-dimensional queries like
queries that are either sequel to power
the product that I mentioned earlier
that's called sequel lab right so
there's an endpoint that you can send
sequel and receive data there's another
endpoint that you can call with
dimensions and metrics and filter
objects and receive data as well so so
here we want to expose that and exposing
that you're like what do we really get
from a data access layer well you get
things like authentication permission
right can this user access this resource
you get things like audit of who queried
what when and and you get you know
caching - right so if you superset knows
how to do caching so that means if
you're building a data product instead
of writing a back-end that that knows
how to query different databases and
craft queries and do like often perm and
caching and auditing well you can just
point assuming that you have a superset
back in at your in your environment you
can just use that embeddable component
is building upon that so it's a set of
react components and a superset client
can a wrapper react component that
allows you to craft or make it really
easy for just anyone to add
visualization to their data product or
web application and the goal there is to
have full-on like interactive components
that you kind of just drop in your app
you don't write any back-end code and
it's just like super fast and you can
get up and up and running quickly adding
interactive data vis component to your
apps schedule simple data pipeline
there's people that lyft working on this
this is very simple don't think about it
like a informatica competitor it's
really just you're in sequel lab you're
writing some sequel you would like to
schedule something
to run every day with a set few simple
dependencies on other resources so we
want to make that something you can do
inside super set so what's next right so
given the positioning that we have right
and we have this backend we have this
this service that does it a lot of
things already there's so much we can do
and I'm running out of time I think I
have like a few minutes I have two
minutes I'm gonna get into these but I
think any one of these point you know I
think are interesting in their own right
and we could talk about but personally
I've been really interested in the idea
of automating the workload of a data
analyst or data scientists and helping
them out around root cause analysis
anomaly detection making a good
dashboard is hard it'd be it'd be great
if we had some sort of wizard that given
a data set would ask you a question
about your key metrics and dimensions
and and in time and time stamps in your
table and help you you know assist you
into creating your dashboard mobile of
course data governance and auditing
right they kept defining who can give
access to what integration with
notebooks I'm not sure but like that
could happen right it seems like a
relevant way that people are working
with data storytelling so here like
there's like so much we could do
probably this is more interesting to
alerts notification right setting up
some rules to get alerted with the right
visualization when things happen so
conclusion as I reach at the end of this
talk so so I'm looking to help like
personally like companies on board so
I'm looking for probably a set of like
companies that are curious about super
said I would like to play with it I'm
starting a new company but the goal is
really not to sell you anything is
really just to partner up and understand
how and help you use super set and
understand more about how it can be used
in different places if you're interested
in working in super set there's
resources here but personally I'm always
like interested in helping people you
know becoming part and growing the
community so if your organization or you
as an individual like want to onboard
and be part doing this community please
shoot me an email
that's all I got thank you very much
yeah thanks for all your help with all
this um I guess knowing what you know
now kind of having been through this
experience if you were to go back and do
it again how would you do it differently
like I love the Apache Software
Foundation but but I might go with a
different software foundation that is
less opinionated on governance and how
things should be run I think they
provide a lot of really good guarantees
and and they've been helpful in general
but I feel like their governance model
is too strict so that's one thing I
would do differently I think for the
rest of like the approach of like
bootstrapping and building things you
know organically you know first like
joining a company like Airbnb or lyft
that that really do sponsor people that
want to work on open source software is
really key right if you're interested in
working an open source join one of these
companies like you know what are you
doing working for a company where you
can't open source your code it was just
too good of a career opportunity to pass
on that and then both my projects Apache
an airflow and super set like I started
open-source from the get-go in the open
from the first commit on in this case it
was a hackathon in the case of airflow I
started the work in between my jobs to
make sure it was gonna be open source
and I would not do that differently
so your so that I'm a counter and
certain your question here what I would
do the same
you